times reported that your Chief of Staff  spent time on a cruise ship in France  for research purposes I wanted to see  what he was trying to figure out there  and let that taxpayer funded you see  what did I go through  I answered a cruise ship question  already I'm not going back and forth on  that when there's something when there's  something to announce more about a  cruise ship  um idea or any other idea I'm gonna  announce it I'm finished with that next  question so you got to see what I have  to deal with over here man I got to deal  with occasionally a reporter asked me a  real question this is ridiculous man  just because my chief of staff embezzled  taxpayer dollars to go on a fancy  vacation in France now I gotta answer  that question no I mean I'm not going to  answer that question you crazy that's  absolutely crazy moving on don't you  dare ask me that question again and then  the crazy part is they just move on